we're getting closer America the second
Republican debate is just two days away
it's presented by Fox Business Network
and will be simulcast right here on the
Fox News Channel at nine o'clock Eastern
It Is co-moderated by our very own Dana
Perino Stuart Varney and univision's
Ilya Calderon seven candidates have
qualified and are ready to take each
other on Dana has been cramming like
crazy and as good co-hosts we'd figured
we'd help her out with some final
preparations got a bunch of questions
and some advice I'll kick things off
Dana in 30 seconds or less how exactly
have you been preparing
with a lot of caffeine now you know I
started with this blank canvas and
probably 170 questions and then you do
the math it's like on the five there's
too many people and too little time so
you got to figure out how are you going
to parse it down so we've been cutting
and deleting I could use a good editor
Jesse I wish you were here with me you
could help me out I will be parsing
um you know
telepathically
judge
hi Dana we miss you first of all do you
think that your experience on the five
has prepared you for this debate
I absolutely do one I was telling
someone I think Greg will remember this
when we first started the five in 2011
we didn't really know what the show was
going to be that we didn't really know
what we were doing and we would all talk
at once and I remember one day getting a
call from the control room saying if you
guys continue to do that we are going to
cancel this show because the audience
can't hear anybody if you're all talking
at once so we have been so much better
about that on the five the candidates in
Milwaukee they weren't great about that
and there's only so much a moderator can
do I'm hoping that they're taking our
advice figure out a way to play Within
the rules and to make sure that you can
get your voice heard because this debate
is a really important one if they want
to keep going
Sandra Oh Dana best of luck to you I
know you're just gonna kill it and it's
gonna be a huge service to voters all
over the country I know you're going to
ask fabulous questions so I was told
either a question or advice and having
moderated to primary GOP debates myself
I thought the best thing I could tell
you was to embrace the unexpected
because I know a lot of the question
planning you're also thinking and
anticipating how that each of the
candidates will respond to those
questions and there will be surprises
and some of those moments will be the
best moments for people at home because
we can learn something about each of the
candidates that perhaps we didn't know
before that night that's excellent
advice and to the judge's previous
question that actually I think that my
experience with all of you on the five
helps a lot in that moment because our
show is completely unscripted and that's
what makes it so good so I think the
other thing I have to really do is make
sure that as a moderator I'm the least
important person in the room but my
ability to listen and really pick up on
a moment that's what I'm going to try to
do Harold who's a very good listener
Joanna congrats great confidence in you
and what you're going to get done out
there leading that group two things for
you how do you allow uh for these people
to answer the question but the same time
compel them to answer the question
whether it's asked by the debater or
fellow debater about you guys and two
how are you going to keep these
Knuckleheads in line at times
I think that we're getting to some
really good questions that don't allow
for them to just pair it back some
talking points that's boring and nobody
wants to hear that so candidates or your
teams their teams if they're watching
just know that and I think moments of
authenticity are super important there
are some debate rules we'll lay them all
out you get a minute for this 30 seconds
for that but if somebody if their name
gets mentioned like if let's say one
Governor says this about another
Governor that person then gets a chance
to respond so I need to really make sure
I understand those rules as well as the
candidates and to make sure that viewers
at home know so that they can tell when
the candidates break in the rules and
not playing nice and being a ball hog
all right let's take it over to our ball
hog Greg
I had the surgery you know what Dana um
I mean this is such
a kind of like an overwhelming
responsibility I mean the stress must
just drive you crazy I honestly don't
know how you're going to pull it off I'm
sure you'll do fine but I was wondering
because you're like me we're both tiny
people what happens if you have to go to
the bathroom
it crossed my mind today and I don't and
you can see behind me that what Fox News
and Fox Business have done to build up a
stage that is absolutely beautiful is
wonderful but Greg I did try to count
the steps to the bathroom I do not think
there is enough time in the commercial
breaks so how do I stay hydrated without
having to
you know the cab drivers
the cab driver's caddy
okay that is great advice if you could
FedEx me one overnight that'd be helpful
I just go to the go to the 7-Eleven get
a bottle well we did FedEx you one thing
I think there's a gift package for you
Dan if you could pull it out over there
and then we could do a little unboxing
in front of everybody here there's some
names on each item so you can okay
unwrap them and announce Percy is not in
this box no that's right okay okay and
it's nothing from the cabbie I
definitely need this this is some from
Greg yeah
there's seven head shots one for every
candidate uh just judge the reaction I
got you some music to inspire you I got
you Slayers rain and blood because you
really like a good thrash metal album
and then I got the best heavy metal
album ever it's the second one it's uh
you know that's five finger death punch
this one feels like what could happen at
the debate yeah the other that there's I
got The Melvins Houdini live in there
the best uh one of the best metal albums
ever if you just there it is that's
Houdini live great and wait you got to
see just plugging out yes and Iggy Pop
raw power he reminds me a lot of you and
then uh the last one look at the last
one I don't know who that is no you got
it right there I don't know who that is
but the album cover is amazing it's not
a giant dog bite no yeah show it to the
audience look at that huh
is that amazing horrifying separated at
Birth yes anyway those are my gifts be
sure not to open them and send it back
to me okay oh judge thank you okay
that's a gavel it's a small one but I
want you to know that I've broken three
during the course of my career as a
judge so you may really have to bang
that Dana to get their attention judge
should I use this or the other thing you
gave me to get them to stop talking
oh Jesse did you give this to me from
your personal collection self-care
so that's a mask to relax after the
debate and also I want you to not get
makeup in your eye you could have some
sort of infection like I got so just
please be careful around the eye tear
duct area okay that is a great advice
here and um let's see for Sandra you
know I need this this is a calculator
The Numbers Never Lie Dana and this this
is uniquely on Fox Business and you know
when a candidate gives you some numbers
that just don't add up you can pull that
out and keep them on track
when they're wrong with the numbers you
can hit them with the floss water
that's great does anybody remember why
we need this okay all right good luck
Dana thank you so much and again I can't
wait to see you in Stuart co-moderate
the debate Wednesday at nine Eastern
it's gonna be great hi winner Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now